Well,
a 23-year-old man was found
dead behind the wheel of a car this
morning. Greetings from Cristian
Casarás, according to the police, the man was
found shot inside a
car in the parking lot of an
apartment complex near
Tropicana and Spencer.  Authorities say
they received calls from multiple
people reporting hearing
gunshots around 4
a.m. and the victim was located a
short time later. Detectives believe
this was an isolated incident and
the City of
Las Vegas Fire Department battled a fire nearby.  of
the times scheduling email on the parkway
according to officials the fire started
inside a dumpster in
a lighting business building the flames
consumed the roof so
firefighters were forced to fight the
fire only from the outside the
business was closed at  the time
of the incident and no injuries were reported
afterwards, which was a situation
worrisome for a community west
of the valley when they saw a cougar
circling the area the animal ended up
in the yard of a home
near el capitan and flamingo streets
after police and the wildlife department tracked it
for several hours
he was eventually killed in
a family's garden and today is the start
of the spring semester for
college students and the omicron strain
is still a concern for
many students according to the college of
southern nevada they have had an increase in
cases and they are  asking that
sick students who present symptoms
stay at home the school is
offering virtual classes and they have
vaccine tests and even reinforcements in
all their campuses
so far the requirement to be
vaccinated to enter the campus is being made an
effort only for employees
and we close with  a look at the
temperatures of the system that brought us
rain during this morning is
continuing its t  rayectoria out of the
valley we will see blue skies for the
rest of the day with temperatures close
to 60 degrees I am cristian cásseres with
super informative Spanish ignition
good day
[Music]